how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have some great news today more
confirmation for guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 guardians of the galaxy vol 3 was
put on hold indefinitely with the firing
of James Gunn the director who directed
guardians of the galaxy volume 1 and
volume 2 so with the firing of James
Gunn and guardians of the galaxy vol 3
being put on hold which was supposed to
come out in 2020 people were starting to
freak out thinking we may not ever get a
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 movie but
today in an interview with Variety Chris
Pratt promised everybody that we will be
getting a guardians of the galaxy vol 3
varieties marc malkin asked Chris Pratt
if we're going to get another guardians
of the galaxy movie Chris Pratt replied
with yeah we're going to see another one
Malcolm VIN went on to ask without James
Gunn though in which Chris Pratt replied
I promise there will be a third movie I
don't know exactly what that's going to
look like but I know everyone on board
is just eager to give the fans what they
want and wrap up a trilogy in a
meaningful way we're still circling the
city of Jericho at the moment so
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 is going
to happen even though his city of
Jericho comment means that they're still
trying to figure things out however we
learn not to long ago from Karen Gillan
the actress that plays nebula that there
is in fact a script for the movie in an
interview with people Karen Gillan said
our director won't be with us any longer
but we are excited to continue the
guardians of the galaxy story and keep
delivering to the fans that's the most
important thing I don't have any details
as to win the next guardians film will
come out but there's a script in
existence she then went on to add I may
have had a little tiny peek but I can't
say anything so it's clear that we're
going to get guardians 3 at some point
in time it's being talked about there's
a script and Chris Pratt just made a
personal promise that we will in fact
get the movie so hopefully we don't have
to wait too much longer to finally see
Adam warlock in the MCU that we were
teased with in the post-credits scene of
guardians 2 I will link the variety
interview with Chris Pratt in the
description down below so you can check
it out for yourself
and let me know in the comments section
how excited you are to finally see
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and if
you're not already don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything Marvel as always thank you
all so much
watching woof-woof
[Music]